I'm an ocean microbiologist at the
University of Tennessee and I want to
tell you guys about some microbes that
are so strange and wonderful but they're
challenging our assumptions about what
life is like on Earth so I have a
question please raise your hand if
you've ever thought it would be cool to
go to the bottom of the ocean in a
submarine yes most of you because the
oceans are so cool all right now please
raise your hand if the reason you raise
your hand to go to the bottom of the
ocean in the submarine is because it
would get you a little bit closer to
that exciting mud that's down there
nobody I'm the only one in this room
well I think about this all the time I
spend most of my waking hours trying to
determine how deep we can go into the
earth and still find something anything
that's alive because we still don't know
the answer to this very basic question
about life on Earth so in the 1980s a
scientist named John parks in the UK was
similarly obsessed and he came up with a
crazy idea he believed that there was a
vast deep in living microbial biosphere
underneath all the world's oceans that
extends hundreds of meters into the sea
floor which is cool but the only problem
is that nobody believed him and the
reason that nobody believed him is that
ocean sediments may be the most boring
place on earth there's no sunlight
there's no oxygen and perhaps worst of
all there's no fresh food deliveries for
literally millions of years you don't
have to have a PhD in biology to know
that that is a bad place to go looking
for life but in 2002 John had convinced
enough people that he was on to
something
that he actually got an expedition on
this drillship called the joy DS
resolution and he ran it along with Bob
our key or instead of Denmark and so
they were finally able to get some
really good pristine deep subsurface
samples without
contamination from surface microbes this
drillship is capable of drilling
thousands of meters underneath the ocean
and the mud comes up in sequential cores
one after the other
long-long cores that look like this this
is being carried by scientists such as
myself who go on these ships and we
process the cores on the ships and then
we send them home to our home
laboratories for further study so when
John and his colleagues got these first
precious deep-sea pristine samples they
put them under the microscope and they
saw images that looked pretty much like
this which has actually taken from a
more recent expedition by my PhD student
joy bon giorno you can see the hazy
stuff in the background that's mud
that's deep deep sea ocean mud and the
bright green dots stained with a green
fluorescent dye are real living microbes
now I got to tell you all something
really tragic about microbes they all
look the same under a microscope I mean
to a first approximation you can take
the most fascinating organisms in the
world like a microbe that literally
breathes
uranium and another one that makes
rocket fuel mix them up with some ocean
mud put them underneath underneath the
microscope and they're just little dots
it's really annoying so we can't use
their looks to tell them apart we have
to use DNA like a fingerprint to say
who's who and I'll teach you guys how to
do it right now
so I made up some data I'm gonna show
you some data that are not real this is
to illustrate what it would look like if
a bunch of species were not related to
each other at all so you can see each
species has a list of combinations of a
G C and T which are the four subunits of
DNA sort of randomly jumbled and nothing
looks like anything else and these
species are totally unrelated to each
other but this is what real DNA looks
like from a gene that these species
happen to share everything lines up
nearly perfectly the chances of getting
so many of those vertical columns for
every species has a C or every species
has a T by random chance is
infinitesimally so we know that all
those species had to have had a common
ancestor they're all relatives of each
other
so now I'll tell you who they are the
top two are US and chimpanzees which you
already knew were related because I mean
obviously but we're also related to
things that we don't look like like pine
trees and Giardia which is that
gastrointestinal disease you can get if
you don't filter your water while you're
hiking
we're also related to bacteria like
e-coli and close tertium difficile which
is a horrible opportunistic pathogen
that kills lots of people there's of
course good microbes too like delicate
coitus empanada knees which cleans up
our industrial waste for us so if I take
these DNA sequences and then I use them
the similarities and differences between
them to make a family tree for all of us
so you can see who's closely related
then this is what it looks like so you
can see clearly at a glance that things
like us and Giardia and bunnies and pine
trees are all like siblings and then the
bacteria are like our ancient cousins
but we're kin to every living thing on
earth so in my job on a daily basis I
get to produce scientific evidence
against existential loneliness so when
we got these first DNA sequences from
the first crews of pristine samples from
the deep subsurface we wanted to know
where they were so the first thing that
we discovered is that they were not
aliens because we could get their DNA to
line up with everything else on earth
but now check out where they go on our
Tree of Life
the first thing you'll notice is that
there's a lot of them it wasn't just one
little species that managed to live in
this horrible place it's kind of a lot
of things and the second thing that
you'll notice hopefully is that they're
not like anything we've ever seen before
there is different from each other as
they are from anything that we've known
before as we are from pine trees so John
parks was completely correct he and we
had discovered a completely new and
highly diverse microbial ecosystem on
earth that no one even knew existed
before the 1980s so now we were on a
roll the next step was to grow these
exotics
species in a petri dish so that we could
do real experiments on them like
microbiologists are supposed to do but
no matter what we fed them they refuse
to grow even now 15 years and many
expeditions later no human has ever
gotten a single one of these exotic deep
subsurface microbes to grow in a petri
dish it's not for lack of trying
that may sound disappointing but I
actually find it exhilarating because it
means there's so many tantalizing
unknowns to work on like for instance my
colleagues and I got what we thought was
a really great idea we were gonna read
their genes like a recipe book find out
what it was they wanted to eat and put
it in their petri dishes and then they
would grow and be happy but then when we
looked at their genes it turns out that
what they wanted to eat was the food we
were already feeding them so that was a
total wash there was something else that
they wanted in their petri dishes that
we were just not giving them so by
combining measurements from many
different places around the world my
colleagues at the University of Southern
California
Doug lero and Yan almond were able to
calculate that each one of these
deep-sea microbial cells requires only
one Zepto watt of power and before you
get your phones outta Zepto is ten to
the minus twenty-one because i know i
would want to look that up humans on the
other hand require about a hundred watts
of power so hundred watts is basically
if you take a pineapple and drop it from
about waist height to the ground
eight hundred and eighty one thousand
six hundred and thirty-two times a day
if you did that and then linked it up to
a turbine that would create enough power
to make me happen for a day a zipped
awhat if you put it in similar terms is
if you take just one grain of salt and
then you imagine tiny tiny little ball
that is one thousandth of the mass of
that one grain of salt and then you drop
it one nanometer which is a hundred
times smaller than the wavelength of
visible light once per day that's all it
takes to make these microbes live that's
less energy than we ever thought would
be capable of supporting life
but somehow amazingly beautifully it's
enough so if these deep subsurface
microbes have a very different
relationship with energy than we
previously thought then it follows that
they'll have to have a different
relationship with time as well because
when you live on such tiny energy
gradients rapid growth is impossible if
these things ever wanted to colonize our
throats and make us sick they would get
muscled out by fast-growing
streptococcus before they could even
initiate cell division so that's why we
never find them in our throats perhaps
the fact that the deep subsurface is so
boring is actually an asset to these
microbes they never get washed out by a
storm they never get overgrown by weeds
all they have to do is exist maybe that
thing that we were missing in our petri
dishes was not food at all maybe it
wasn't a chemical maybe the thing that
they really want the nutrient that they
want is time the time is the one thing
that I'll never be able to give them so
even if I have a cell culture that I
passed to my PhD students who pass it's
their PhD students and so on we'd have
to do that for thousands of years in
order to mimic the exact conditions of
the deep subsurface all without growing
any contaminants it's just not possible
but maybe in a way we already have grown
them in our petri dishes maybe they
looked at all that food that we offered
them and said thanks I'm gonna speed up
so much that I'm gonna make a new cell
next century so why is it that the rest
of biology moves so fast
why does a cell die after a day and a
human dies after only a hundred years
they seem like really arbitrarily short
limits when you think about the total
amount of time in the universe but these
are not arbitrary limits they're
dictated by one simple thing and that
thing is the Sun whence life figured out
how to harness the energy of the Sun
through photosynthesis we all had to
speed up and get all day and night
cycles in that way the Sun gave us both
a reason to be fast and the fuel to do
it you can view most of life on earth
like a circulatory system and the Sun is
our beating heart
the deep subsurface is like a
circulatory system that's completely
disconnected from the Sun it's instead
being driven by long slow geological
rhythms there's currently no theoretical
limit on the lifespan of one single cell
as long as there is at least a tiny
energy gradient to exploit theoretically
a single cell could live for hundreds of
thousands of years or more simply by
replacing broken parts of our time to
ask a microbe that lived like that to
grow in our petri dishes is to ask them
to adapt to our frenetic Sun centric
fast way of living and maybe they've got
better things to do than that imagine if
we could figure out how they managed to
do this what if it involves some cool
ultra stable compounds that we could use
to increase the shelf life in biomedical
or industrial applications or maybe if
we figure out the mechanism that they
use to grow so extraordinarily slowly we
could mimic it in cancer cells and slow
runaway cell division I don't know
I mean honestly that is all speculation
but the only thing I know for certain is
that there are a hundred billion billion
billion living microbial cells
underlying all the world's oceans that's
200 times more than the total biomass of
humans on this planet and those microbes
have a fundamentally different
relationship with time and energy than
we do what seems like a day to them
might be a thousand years to us they
don't care about the Sun and they don't
care about growing fast and they
probably don't give a damn about my
petri dishes but if we can continue to
find creative ways to study them then
maybe we'll finally figure out what
life's all of life is like on earth
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]